In Südkorea ist am Sonntag eine erste Delegation
aus dem Norden eingetroffen, die die Teilnahme
an den Olympischen Winterspielen vorbereiten
soll.
Die Gruppe organisiert die Konzerte eines
nordkoreanischen Orchesters,
das während der Spiele auftritt.
Die Delegation war bereits am Vortag erwartet
worden, hatte die Reise jedoch kurzfristig
abgesagt, ohne Gründe zu nennen.
Neben den 140 Musikern werden nach Angaben
des Internationalen Olympischen Komitees 22 Athleten aus dem Norden erwartet.
Die Sportler würden in drei Sportarten und
fünf Disziplinen antreten, teilte der Verband am Samstag mit.
Nord- und Südkorea hätten zugestimmt, unter
einer gemeinsamen
Flagge an der Eröffnungszeremonie teilzunehmen.
Auch werde ein gemeinsames koreanischen Frauen-Eishockeyteam
antreten.
Nordkorea schicke zudem 24 Funktionäre und
21 Medienvertreter in den Süden.
Die Spiele finden vom 9. bis zum 25.
Februar im südkoreanischen Pyeongchang statt.